hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to the homeroom live
stream we're very excited to have a
conversation with u.s secretary of
education miguel cardona today but
before we jump into that conversation i
will remind you a few of the my typical
reminders first of all
uh khan academy is a not-for-profit
organization we can only exist through
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please go
to khan academy.org slash donate i also
want to make a special shout out to
several organizations that have stepped
up especially during the pandemic many
of y'all know that our traffic tripled a
year ago when we uh went to the pandemic
a lot of more folks have been leaning on
us our server costs went up and so
special thanks to bank for america at t
google.org novartis fastly and general
motors
and many other supporters of khan
academy to stepping up and making sure
that we're in a position to support
millions tens of millions of learners
around the world uh so thank you for
that and i also want to remind folks
that there is a version of this live
stream in podcast form wherever you get
your podcasts homeroom with sal the
podcast so please check that out
so with that i am very excited to
introduce dr miguel cardona u.s
secretary of education secretary cardona
thank you for joining us hey happy to be
here in homeroom happy to be here
so so maybe a great place for folks to
start i think
people know secretary of education
federal government it's the most senior
education leader in the country
but from your vantage point what do you
see as the role the job the potential of
us secretary of education
you know supporting kids that supporting
students uh from pre-k to to higher
education really it it's really making
sure i'd like to think i i
this role is really it really needs to
be the the greatest child advocate uh in
the country to make sure that our
education program is meeting the needs
of all of our students the diverse needs
of our students and making sure that
we're
uh letting education be that great
equalizer that it was for me
and how do you view that do you view it
as is it advocacy what are the levers at
your disposal the the us
famously has a very you know it's a very
federated system in education a lot of
the resources are happening at the state
and the local government
where does your role fit in in the whole
ecosystem
sure so you know working with states
working with local districts to help
support them right now as we recover
from this pandemic uh funding is there's
more funding coming from the federal
government uh but you know making sure
that uh we're using this position to
support to elevate best practices to use
the position as a bully pulpit around
those things that we know work for kids
and those things that we should be doing
in education but also a policy level too
making sure that
we're advocating and also protecting the
rights of students that are uh
they deserve a free and appropriate
public education throughout our country
and i definitely want to get into some
of those policy questions and i think
it's an exciting time to be in education
generally i'm imagining a very exciting
time to be secretary of education
there's so much to do there's never been
more energy i think behind education
potentially more funding behind
education is what we're starting to see
but before we jump into that i want to
remind everyone you can ask your
questions on youtube and facebook i'll
try to surface as many of the questions
as we can to secretary cardona but i'd
like to know a little bit about your
life journey i don't think a lot of kids
wake up in the morning when they're you
know seven years old and says i will be
u.s secretary of education in 2021. so
what was that pathway what got you here
listen i grew up my parents came from
puerto rico when they were in their
teens and um
you know my my grandparents moved to for
a better life you know my grandfather
cut sugar cane in puerto rico and you
know the money was paying a little bit
better in in hartford when hartford
connecticut where you cut tobacco so he
settled in meridian he left a beautiful
paradise island over there
palm trees and beaches to go live in the
fourth floor of apartment projects and
um in a place where he didn't know the
language didn't know the culture but he
did that so that he could provide for
his family my parents uh were born they
lived in that same community and early
on sal i
i
i was modeled uh service to community
right and uh the schools gave me so much
so i ended up becoming an educator but
service to the community was really what
i wanted to do for my life and i just it
took me from a classroom teacher fourth
grade teacher to secretary of education
but at the end of the day it's still
service
and did you fill in the blanks a little
bit because you said you know service
classroom teacher
secretary of education but how does that
happen you know what did you did you go
into administration what was that
journey like
i went to uh a technical high school
because
you know we had a big family in meridian
and my eldest cousin went to a technical
high school so all the little cousins
followed you know like little ducks
crossing the road
and it was a great experience i learned
automotive technology for four years and
i had a teacher that said you know
miguel you should consider teaching so i
wanted to go become an art teacher and
i went to college thinking i was going
to become an art teacher i love the arts
and
again teaching is an extension of
service right so i went into college but
i gravitated toward elementary education
i became a fourth grade teacher i loved
that role i never wanted to leave the
classroom but i got asked and pushed
into administration by the
superintendent at the time then i became
a elementary school principal for 10
years loved that role
really engaged with families i served
students with disabilities i served
students that were learning english as a
second language we had children with
developmental delays we had children
with multiple handicaps it was a really
wonderful learning experience for me
i became an assistant superintendent in
that district i did a little work
teaching at the college level and then
the governor of connecticut called for
me to serve as
uh commissioner of education and i
enjoyed that role i'm really passionate
about addressing inequities in education
then the pandemic hit
um and you know we
work really hard to try to safely reopen
schools in connecticut and that work and
you know that passion
got me a call from uh the president of
the united states so now i'm fortunate
to be serving as
uh secretary of education
you know i definitely want to get into
what you hope to do in this role now and
and some of the policy questions but i i
want to double click again on this you
know just talking to you i can send some
of your energy and the passion for what
you do so it's not surprising but what
do you think it was you know what do you
think it was about that teacher that
said that maybe you should become a
teacher what did they see in you and
then what do you think other folks have
seen in you or you saw in yourself that
allowed you to go on this this very very
impressive journey
you know what's special about me that
there's nothing special about me that i
represent every student in the classroom
that you know just wants to do well and
wants to serve and i had a teacher
just realize that i was using my artwork
to communicate my values so there was a
mural that i did sell
back then you know there were
it was like late 80s early 90s and i did
a mural that said there's only one race
the human race and i had um in that
mural all these different uh characters
with from different backgrounds and
different cultural traditions different
dress
and the teacher said you know why don't
you make that a mural in the cafeteria
so she saw that i was using my art to
communicate my values and
you know so she gave me that opportunity
and that really made me feel like well i
could do this
and it's important to name those folks
by name so linda ransom
was that teacher
who saw that in me and and said why
don't you consider a career in education
and that's what did it so it was really
a teacher seeing something in me
that uh i can communicate through arts
and
that's all it took and i was hooked
after that
no i i'm so glad you you highlighted in
that way because it's very easy to say
what does the governor see in you or
what did the you know what what did a
school leader see in you but you're
you're so right it's those teachers
early on in your life that when you
might you know for me and you're right
it's important to name them octavio
hernandez my algebra teacher and he was
he was our mentor for for the math club
i was a little bit of a of a math nerd
all right dr santania who was a
professor at uno and i didn't have a
computer at home and he let me use his
computers while i was i was doing some
dual enrollment things in high school so
you're absolutely right it's those
teachers that make uh all the difference
in the world you know and all sorts of
questions are coming in so i want to
make sure i have time to get to all
these questions but i do want to you
know now that you are in this role and
it's still the first few months of of
your of your tenure here
what are what are your hopes and fears
what are you hoping and you know if we
look back on this in 10 years that like
yes we we were able to do x y and z and
and what are your fears on top of that
you know 59 days to be exact uh
but
we need to we hit the ground running and
we're going to continue running i know
that there's a finite window to serve as
secretary of education and there's such
need
since we've been collecting data there
have been gaps in outcomes for students
and you know we have to make sure that
we're gonna we're gonna address that i
don't think there's ever been a time in
the history of our education system
where we've been as close to a reset
button as we are now
so yes you know the pandemic really did
a number on our country and you know
we're it's going to take time to real
reel in from that
but i want to seize this opportunity to
rethink
some of those things that we've been
doing that are maybe not best for kids
or maybe really just reimagine how we
can
reopen our doors not only physically and
make sure the lights are on but just
rethink how we're educating our students
and how we're partnering with families
and how we're listening to students in
this process of reopening and recovering
are there certain areas that you are
particularly excited about you're right
you know with a pandemic and education
you know i've been in this game for a
little while as well and i've never seen
so much energy behind education because
it's a bit of a reboot reset because of
the pandemic but where do you see as the
opportunities and and where do you see
the risks right now sure so tremendous
opportunities you know
i'm talking to an innovative genius here
right i remember hearing your name in a
cafeteria
at hanover school over 10 12 years ago
where a teacher said hey check out these
videos and
look it now you know my kids it kind of
khan academy is a is a topic at the
dinner table and most houses uh where
where i've been an educator
so how do we allow innovation to really
drive where we're going how do we kind
of
you know revisit those things that are
uh
sacred cows that maybe are not
in the best interest of students so when
we're looking at time time in seats how
we utilize technology how we use blended
learning you know blended learning is
something that happened overnight and
we're just getting better how we're
closing the digital divide to make sure
we have greater access to learning so
that i'm not limited to the experiences
that i have in my community or in my
schoolhouse you know those are some
areas of innovation um we can have
students connecting with students across
the country just like i'm connecting
with you some of the fears
some of the fears so while we're
pleased to see that about 80 percent of
the pre-k 8 schools have some form of
in-person learning at this point we know
that um the data is disproportionate by
race we know that um
black and brown students um and asian
students are less likely to go into
school even if that option is there so
what we've seen happen in this past year
is a gross exacerbation of opportunities
and and outcomes for our students based
on
not only race but also where they live
right so rural communities have been
impacted significantly based on the fact
that uh the internet connection maybe
isn't as strong so we have a lot of work
to do there and my fear is that
we don't maintain the level of urgency
that we need
to really reshape where we're going
that that would be my greatest fear that
our urgency dissipates over time
yeah no completely completely understand
that last notion you know there's a a
group of just through the work we do at
khan academy of superintendents and
state commissioners your old job um that
we've connected with and i even get them
together on a zoom every other friday
now to discuss some of these topics and
they're all feeling exactly what you're
feeling this is an unusual moment
the pandemic has been incredibly hard
especially on some of the communities
that frankly were already needed some
some extra support because of various
contexts pre-pandemic
and and now there's a unique opportunity
to to hopefully solve the problems that
the pandemic was introduced but also
move ahead and there's incredible you
know federal dollars coming way there's
the third round of stimulus had a lot of
dollars that are coming from the federal
government and i know y'all are
proposing more that i want to talk about
where do you see have you have you seen
examples are there things in the back of
y'all's mind that you see like you know
that's going to be a really good use of
these funds i think it averages 800 or
900 per student in america and it and in
certain areas it might be as much as two
or three thousand dollars so it's
significant resources for the next three
years
you know i have to start with uh social
emotional well-being of students
what i'm finding is that you know we are
still in the middle of a pandemic and we
can't think that just because the lights
are on and the hallways are clean and
the doorknobs have been wiped down that
we can go back to business as usual
many of our students have experienced a
lot of loss whether it's loss of loved
ones or you know loss of uh jobs or
their parents being underemployed now or
having to change and not seeing uh loved
ones for for a long period of time so we
have to make sure that when we reopen
schools we're ready and prepared to meet
our students where they are and provide
them that support that they need to be
emotionally safe so that bandwidth for
learning uh can grow so that's one of
the areas where i see that that's
working another area that i'm noticing
with the help is here tour is that in
those places where there's intentional
collaboration
right so in collaboration that's deeper
than it was prior to the pandemic those
are the places that are reopening
quicker and more safe
more safe and allowing for innovation to
take root earlier so it's really some of
those underlying things like that social
emotional well-being of our students of
our educators but also making sure that
we reorganize so that we're more
responsive to the needs of the community
that's how we're going to get students
back in and that's how we're going to
get families to re-engage so funds for
educators to help
lower class sizes especially for those
students that were hit hardest by the
pandemic and maybe haven't been in a
schoolhouse for over a year more social
uh workers more school counselors
better tools for teachers better
training for teachers you know we we
keep asking teachers to do more and more
and more we need to make sure we embed
professional learning opportunities in a
creative way too it can't be just
packing more into those three pd days
that they get so we really need to
rethink those things but those states
that are using the funds to provide
social emotional support
good after school programming that are
hands-on good summer learning
opportunities for students to get out
into the community and do uh camp-like
activities and and learn with their
hands and discovery learning those are
the places that are finding the most
success with reopening but those are the
ones that are really utilizing their
funds to address the needs of the
students
you know i love that answer because i
think in education because the things we
measure often things like test scores
and reading or math we can become very
obsessed with test scores and it is at
least in my opinion important to measure
these things to understand where you are
but when we face a situation like this
it's very tempting to immediately get
into how do we get back fill in the gaps
fill in the academic gaps but to your
point and i've seen this as a father and
we've seen this in the work at khan
academy if you don't have
if the kids aren't in the right place
from a social emotional point of view if
there isn't the right collaboration
amongst the adults there's not the right
training amongst the adults it doesn't
matter what
tools you provide it doesn't matter what
curricula you provide you're not going
to get the same outcomes and the other
way around if you do have good social
emotional if you do have good
collaboration
it also does not matter what kind of
curricula you have you'll probably have
a good a good outcome so i think that's
a very a very powerful notion
absolutely we have to start with where
the students are where their children
are you know someone once told me when i
was student teaching
she was a teacher for students with
disabilities she said miguel don't
forget you teach
children not curriculum you teach kids
not curriculum and that stuck with me
we need to start with where the students
are and right now they need to feel a
safe school environment they need to
have the relationship
the r that r before the reading writing
arithmetic i think it could be done
together but we cannot
we cannot skip past that that social
emotional well-being of our students but
also our staff
that makes a ton of sense and then you
know one extra layer as you know you
know for khan academy to do its work
there needs to be some level of
connectivity devices obviously it's not
just khan academy it opens up a whole
new world there's another not-for-profit
effort spawned in in
in reaction to the pandemic around free
tutoring called schoolhouse.world once
again kids are not going to access
things like this
unless they have
access
how are you thinking about the digital
divide i know the american rescue
package had several billions of dollars
for it how confident are you that we're
gonna we're gonna crack that nut
i'm very i'm very confident listen the
digital divide should be a thing it's in
our rearview mirror soon yes it's going
to take bold actions but the bold
funding is there and the direction is
there and the guidance is that we have a
president that gets it so let's go let's
close the digital divide we all know the
laptop is the new pencil so let's move
forward and let's open the doors for
students that's a basic level of equity
that we need to provide i know states
and and communities are thinking about
it
that thinking has been accelerated with
the pandemic the tools are there the
resources are there let's just get it
done and let's talk about quality
instruction and recognizing that
that that's a tool to get to good uh
educational opportunities so i really
feel strongly in connecticut one of the
things we did is we prioritize with the
governor's leadership and the state
department of education's leadership we
prioritize closing that digital divide
because we know that um you know it's
not only about getting the the the
computer up and the internet access it's
also about getting quality content on
the other side of that screen and that's
critically important that's how gaps are
exacerbated when we don't have quality
content so the first step is getting a
device good connectivity and then
quality content those three things are
important it makes a ton of sense and
i want to get to everyone's questions
but i have so many myself so i'm going
to indulge myself you know y'all i've
actually never seen any administration
and i think the pandemic is part of it
but i've never seen anyone with as bold
tangible
plans around education as we're starting
to see on the american families plan and
i'm reading this you know 200 billion
for free universal preschool 109 billion
for free community college uh 80 billion
for pell grants and and that's that's
not the complete list but that's a lot
of dollars you know 200 billion for free
universal preschool for three and
four-year-olds i think there's about 10
or 11
million uh three and four-year-olds in
the country so that that comes out to if
i'm doing the math right something like
twenty thousand 000
per per student to give them that pre-k
and and as a father of young children i
appreciate more than anyone how much
that creates an advantage or support for
kids we've invested in it at khan
academy kids but
how hopeful are you that these things
are going to pass and then how do you
see them getting implemented because
there are obviously a lot of preschools
but we don't have a public preschool
infrastructure how do you see that money
flowing down
right so you know first and foremost you
know those are technical strategies uh
that are being um
recommended by a president who gets
what we need to do who gets that
education is the foundation of this
country that education is the best
economic driver not only for our country
but for these individuals we know that
students are more likely to graduate if
they have uh pre-k experiences and more
likely to take higher level courses
honors courses we know that college
graduates community college graduates
boost their earning potential by 21
everyone wins here so we have a
president that gets it the funds are are
aimed at providing additional four years
of school for uh for the students to
give them a leg up as he said last night
you know we are competing with the world
and he gets that we have to be bold to
invest in our students i mean where
better can we invest right in our
children across the country to make sure
that they have the opportunity to
succeed in life and that our country can
continue to grow i am confident that
there's going to be
a support behind this and i do believe
that you're right the implementation
matters but educators have shown this
past year that they could rise to the
challenge and that they're prepared to
put the students first and when making
decisions and we need to act with the
same level of urgency that our president
has
towards supporting children and we're
gonna get we're gonna get it done we're
gonna get it done
yeah no absolutely it's very inspiring i
have a bunch of questions coming in
these are actually from two colleagues
of mine one is nick breen on facebook
says will the two years of free
community college aspect of the plan be
available to all fields of study and
kristin deterbo who's actually kind of
academy's chief learning officer is
asking we continue to see students
entering community colleges without the
reading writing and math skills they
need to be successful often these
students get stuck in developmental math
programs how do we support these so i
kind of view those as as you know two
sides of the same coin fantastic
questions and i think you know they do
connect right so we know that uh our
students that when they go to college
and they're they're still not reading at
grade level that there's work that has
to be done at the k-12 level so i'm
really hopeful that the uh rescue plan
and the cares plan uh really and then
the budget that the president is putting
forward supports strong k-12 pre-k 12
learning and high standards for all
students across the country so we don't
have that issue and then the community
college connection to the high schools
we have to make sure that those programs
while the details of what programs would
be accepted under that what i want to
see sell is a better connection between
our high school actually our middle
school high school and two-year colleges
so that we provide students with viable
pathways into the workforce in careers
that exist now careers that will exist
five years from now so that these
students can take advantage of those two
years and really go into the workforce
or continue to a four-year program and
continue to get their education those
connections between the community
college and our middle and high schools
is one of the goals for me there has to
be a more clear through lines so more
students take advantage of it and they
lead to careers that these students want
to do that are needed now
i couldn't agree more you know one of
the questions that i always wonder and
this goes off for christian's question
is you know you know the stats right now
65 70 of all kids who show up at
community college they don't even place
into college algebra they place into
remedial math which is essentially
pre-algebra sixth or seventh grade
mathematics and we also know that
college algebra
one when you don't place into it's a
huge signal that you're not going to
graduate and you're going to have debt
and that college algebra itself is a
huge gaining factor for a lot of kids
even though it really should have been
taught in 9th or tenth grade algebra one
and algebra two are essentially college
algebra
i'm fascinated and i'd love your advice
at khan academy and this free tutoring
platform schoolhouse.world we're
creating how it can help teachers and
students
get
maybe ways we could partner with
universities to get college algebra
credit before they even
leave high school are you thinking
things like that so that college algebra
should just be off the table so it
shouldn't be a gating factor anymore
you know one of the things we learn in
this pandemic is we have to think
outside the box
so we need to really make sure that
we're providing opportunities for
students to learn these things and it
doesn't have to be during the regular
school day it could be we could be
creative
but i want to take it back a little bit
further they're not they're not
accessing those classes or not passing
those classes in eighth or ninth grade
because maybe in third grade they were
at a first grade reading level and maybe
in first grade they were still learning
their letters so this uh universal pre-k
pre-kindergarten and early childhood
focus that the president is is providing
here will help alleviate some of those
issues as well so yes we have to get
creative for those students that are uh
underserved and that we haven't gotten
to that point where they're passing
those courses but when we have a strong
foundation in early childhood education
it's less likely that that pattern is
going to continue so i'm really pleased
with that focus
from president biden and i know that if
implemented well those issues are going
to start going away because we're going
to better prepare our students early and
the gaps that we see when our three and
four and five-year-olds come in are
going to be diminished when we have
strong programs at the early childhood
level it's all connected
and i i i think i could predict what you
might say but what's your view on the
the student debt crisis i i didn't see
that i mean it's implicitly addressed in
some of the things like free community
college and more pell grants but we know
it's over a trillion dollars of debt i
have even people in my family who are in
their 40s who are still paying off debt
or maybe even some cases given up um
how can we
what can we do there that can help
unlock a lot of folks
that's a major issue and you know it's a
two-prong approach the first prong is
making sure we can do what we can to
support students that are in debt now
and we're having conversations about
what that might look like but the second
step too that i don't think gets
discussed as much but we really need to
focus on is ensuring that it doesn't
happen again that we have public service
loan forgiveness that actually works you
know we've had a system that rejects
like 98
of the applicants that's unacceptable we
have to do borrower defense better we
have to make sure that our colleges are
providing a good return on investment uh
for these learners that are coming in
especially these first gen students you
know i read a fact recently that
some borrowers
are in greater debt 12 years later
because they were never able to knock
down the principle so
we have to fix that we have to make sure
we have pathways to college that are
affordable so uh more students take
advantage of that so it's a two-prong
approach yes we're going to look at uh
potential loan forgiveness conversation
and making sure that we're supporting
those who are in major debt but we're
also going to make sure that we're
stopping the bleeding by
promoting good practices that will
alleviate some of this uh this debt
accumulation that we see in our students
yeah and it seems like even our
bankruptcy laws are a little bit strange
it's easier to cancel your debt when you
you know you max out a credit card or
you run a business into the ground then
you know if if you're you're not able to
uh cover all of all of your your student
debt there should be a penalty which is
bankruptcy your credit score gets but at
least there's a way that's why
bankruptcy exists to it to reboot well
folks on board that have a
student-centered approach to the
policies that we're making and ensuring
that we're not in this position again in
five years absolutely i'm looking
forward to having more work done on this
issue
no i mean it's very uh inspiring to hear
that you know i know we're almost out of
time you're super busy uh
first of all let me just say i consider
what we're doing at khan academy uh what
we're trying to do at schoolhouse.world
these are in service to hopefully the
same mission and vision so you know
consider us at your service of how we
can move the dial for learners and
teachers and parents in america but i'd
love to you know for you to finish up
with any messages you have we have a lot
of teachers a lot of parents a lot of
children watching right now
thank you very much and thanks for the
invite it was nice to be this is a long
home room usually homeroom is about 10
minutes so this is nice that we had a
30-minute home room but you know my
message is first of all thank you sal
for everything that you've done in
education and supporting educators
supporting students across the country
really appreciated my own children i
have a 14 year old and 16 year old who
benefit from khan academy and i just
want to say thank you for what you've
done but to the educators and the
families
i want to say thank you for what you've
done this past year but no we have an
opportunity to hit the reset button and
really elevate our practices and making
sure that we're supporting our educators
supporting our students in different
ways so that all students have access to
a quality education
you know and we're going to do it
together one thing that i learned that
intentional collaboration is how we're
going to move ahead as a country so i
look forward uh to working with you sal
with the families with educators to make
sure we can do the very best for all the
students across the country again thanks
for letting me be on
well secretary cardona this was a real
honor and i'll say it again your energy
get you know you're you're only 59 days
in but your energy and your background
and your experience gives me very high
hopes for what uh we're as a country
going to be able to accomplish together
so thank you so much for your service
here
all right take care
well well thanks everyone for joining uh
hopefully you enjoyed that conversation
as much as i did as i always say these
conversations go far faster than
time flies when you're having fun i wish
we could have spoken for for another few
hours uh but i i have hopes uh that you
know uh i've never seen more energy uh
at the federal level behind education
part of it's from from the pandemic part
of it is it feels like just where uh the
my the headspace is right now and uh you
know i think there's there is an
opportunity that that all collectively
that we can imagine a a really exciting
world together so thanks everyone for
joining and i look forward to seeing you
in in future homerooms
you